so I got jump
[Music]
make the pudding barrels here oh yeah
but it's arrows party service party
because I owe me if you give me lip
again goggles only an hour and a half
away buddy I'm coming I'm coming for you
LeBron LeBron James is coming to the
Lakers yeah my whole clippers fun one of
the people that compares that compare
stats of Kobe de
two to LeBron now all the Kobe fans are
gonna be LeBron fan Kobe and 154 million
Jesus oh now that are worth more than
what rec screen black screen to so for
Craig remember people sponsored by yummy
yawns hey
we don't want to do all right
so this one this one's not as long it's
like a short it's like a glorified
strike it's like a six players strike
but yeah yeah you got a coordinator
oh yeah yeah coordinate I know and so
it's gonna be it should make for a good
[ __ ] wow this is a lot you know what
three people on the screen it's a little
bit too much now saying when you're
looking at the screen like your fear how
do people under twitch think well
they're probably watching my remember
this I think am I going in the right
place just follow everybody else aro
you're on in yours eight nine yeah
oh [ __ ] you know what I think what was
the point of all that you know that just
start us here it looks cool
are you a nice place we've done this a
new Raider like a leapfrog brand balls
no way will the brand it won't rain
because you don't do anything PvE base
in this game grind but I don't need to
think your life allows you to play the
new ring yeah really why
what'll I do you have to have you gotta
be on the mic son you gotta be you gotta
be a way higher light and [ __ ] what
is Craig what is Craig where is he I'm
not high 360 yeah you know you ain't
even there alright so so how this works
yeah yeah yeah we follow one minute I
know we did this the person have you
so we'll go aero peak to me no I'll go
west
I'll go less so it'll go peak to arrow
hype Griffin Craig okay so follow the
person in front of you
what arrow arrow let's go let's go I'm
Stone Roses like a little [ __ ] be broke
I'm throwing roses
yeah have a good time it's okay yeah all
right so this one this one we gotta talk
to me
this one we got to so I'll start right
I'll be fir are all be last wants to be
first right oh that's right we got to
yeah okay I'll be first I'll be first
right yep I'll follow you okay Craig
Craig will be cokes group okay stop
shoot I'll be after what no okay then
I'm gonna go out to this I'm gonna have
to Pikachu I was already over I don't
know [ __ ] up how many [ __ ] gone hey
Griffin Griffin Griffin I know who's
comin love
there's I'm coming after you can I go on
there now with you you know I want to
know okay oh my plates gonna drop yeah
don't worry
now you're fine oh my god doesn't
already like ridiculous wise Pikachu
jump in yes oh [ __ ]
good shot at my [ __ ] is word where the
[ __ ] the [ __ ] happened
someone didn't move up Craig I think I
can make know somebody didn't move up
dude that's what they're saying
I bet it was Pikachu it wasn't him
probably was I'm not first let's try
this again
alright well we just ii want to get do
the first one again no there's no second
one second one oh [ __ ] again if buddy's
shootin at us man they're already up
there
oh [ __ ] almost died
hey close the door when you leave Gavin
please oh here we go
shut the [ __ ] up okay I know here we go
with Gavin Gavin did you do the dishes
what's going on run as fast as you can
oh my god Jesus [ __ ] me up I think we
got another image I think we got enough
we did we got everyone good okay so how
do I get over there and all the swells
about just run across yeah yeah whatever
this is no we have to like jump twice
right just follow just follow there
anybody coming down here or am I just
going
I'm second I'll go after coke later guys
just follow just follow a little RX man
follow the reason that the person I'm
just gonna go yeah I did [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah you did you guys see that
[ __ ] no it was [ __ ] coke
might drive an hour to [ __ ] who's
going next I'll go next okay I'll follow
people oh my god okay where am I am I
going
isn't this the one that splits left
yeah laughing right yeah whose is it
whose long life is of me okay I'm
following that is follow yeah I heard
them dingoes yes I'm just
speaking English here how did they
respawn that's what I want to know not
ship came and dropped him off Monster
High yep hey who came up with this
nonsense man I just wanna kill [ __ ]
shoot it stuff destiny 101 jumping what
are we playing
what are you playing jeopardy that'd be
awesome little mini game destiny
jeopardy and this is all about like
everybody might think your age is this
is little Liberty I'll take oh my god
I mean it I did I was good enough we got
enough
if we didn't build that platform in
laying down there we got a white we'll
see what happens
wait why did it build you guys stuck
back there no no we're going it is built
it's fine we're getting there no you
don't understand if we didn't tag that
last platform
don't die Craig oh oh that shot that was
a big jump I just made yeah the one
thing the Warlock jump is good for the
blight is phenomenal
yeah just fall out such a like oh good
Maggie that was great we got that right
on camera so now what I'm going to this
one we'll have them go in the order
everybody go like you up
Oh somebody's not behind me no that's
what doesn't matter I'll mines are
turning red I'd see some last okay
now do you take this next one or do I I
take this yeah oh my god
Craig move I did [ __ ] that's [ __ ] up
all right just go make it I think we
touched the last plate though so yep
you get prawns I'm just gonna get AIDS
now I see one platform [ __ ]
what are we do sighs noticing but now
I'm noticing this time what is he doing
so we all have to kind of leave it let
me just clarify for the last plate
though so with coke you jump on that
plate right then who goes next boat you
go right but that goes clarify this
right so we get soda split it's gonna
get to a point where it ends in the
middle so either we could go about it
two different ways the reason we switch
on in office because those plates get
red so by the time right by the time
arrow kind of meets up with me then it
gets to a point where it puts the plate
in the middle of us I go you guys wait
on arrow side and then we just we
continue we continue the same thing okay
so it goes you then like let's say it's
hide version so when it hyped me so when
it's split when it split no I'll stay
then I'll stay
hmm all semester hike all right I'll
just ask you when we get there I'll just
ask them together oh god no because I'm
just [ __ ] so I so so look how it
goes now you guys switch around yes
we're Griffin and them are going K Hyde
goes one more he goes so arrows on that
so now people know peak - yeah it's
[ __ ] Pikachu that's what it was
alright I see that's what I want enough
alright I'll keep shoes a piece of [ __ ]
see it you see it I understand it
believe it
there we go oh all right apparently me
look at Pete Jimmy this is the third
time you've been back there god damn it
do we get enough people
well if we don't I'm [ __ ] catching a
flight tomorrow out to [ __ ] LA or
wherever peak to that I'm gonna [ __ ]
injectors to work and be like Yui I'm
not serving up salads bro I'm throwing
down with the fisticuffs and you're
you're gonna [ __ ] take it all right
at the Chuck E Cheese I was trying to
kill these guys up here did you get a
marrow wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute wait so why are these two
plates up all right I'm gonna go to the
far one somebody come behind all right
I'll go next
I'll go night and this one just follow
just follow the person ahead there's
only one part where you have to jump
over over a plain ones right so just
watch kisses just watch the person yes
so wherever they go that's where you go
nightmare so I got jumping yeah yeah
literally follow me try go Pikachu go
though jump jump
Pikachu
all right you go first I'll go second
coming yeah because you just jump to the
next one that's the easiest thing to do
is no cuz you have to skip that one and
that's where Pikachu but I know I know
but it becomes weird when there's always
that one [ __ ] in the group behind my
thing is red who push no that's I got
this straight
[Laughter]
[Music]
literally literally
whenever somebody goes to a plate you go
to the same [ __ ] played you the next
one you gotta jump over it and then
you're gonna jump to the middle
oh good that bubble wait a minute yeah
where's Craig that bubble [ __ ] I know
it does kind of [ __ ] it up okay yeah all
right yeah I'm going last where am I
going next you're going after height
I just I don't know if it'll help you
guys if you emote you go third-person
you get a bigger window you know
wherever yeah don't tell that to Pikachu
we started to dance it's a bad idea
okay here it is right here moment of
truth okay here it is okay I have to go
way over there got it okay we did it we
did it we did it well we're not done yet
you know I do aw Fe got even better at
what we're good at which is being
terrible by Ronnie's pinko like we we
made up
we made a power play when we picked up
peak issues yeah
[Laughter]
Griffen Griffen forgot how to press the
a button Griffin for da man okay okay so
let's take let's let's take let's take
15 seconds let's all breathe okay now
Pikachu Pichu look at me where are you
at where are you got beat you Phil
Jackson here Peter
alright when you're going on these
[ __ ] these [ __ ] things down here
these totems what are the platforms
look at me peak - don't look at the
platforms look at me okay literally if
I'm following if I'm following hike look
at my guy you see home I'm looking at
height look at the guy ahead of you the
entire time do not look around do not
confuse yourself if you're getting shot
swerve like this straight back and forth
that the snipers won't hate you
alright that's all got it you need to do
we're just we just believe some healing
riffs on the thing - yup - good idea we
got we got these er beams coming out of
us quickly
I really hate following Pikachu Lucas if
he jumps the wrong spot I'm going for
again what are you talking about
okay guys I'm gonna [ __ ] cruise
that's fair Erol all hasn't [ __ ] up
yet he gets a chance look at credit
Colin Ivy gets to tell who's who gets a
chance no I'm not saying arrows no what
I'm saying is you have no right saying
arrow gets a chance like it's it's like
it's a given it's a given you don't even
get to say that you know I'm waiting for
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah people wouldn't watch for the game
cane this is just chaotic I just wanna
know who's the idiot that came up with
this in the first place this is just
some sadistic nonsense they're probably
like well as an easy entry to the actual
raid we're just going to do a game of
follow-the-leader and we can't [ __ ]
do it they test the bar for they launch
almost there guys welcome father sighs I
don't think we went to right way oh my
god now in the railway yeah you did yeah
you did don't worry no my Tainos sons
got bad yet
okay we did it one more now we got one
more go oh no Peaks we got everyone
please make [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
pushing me off oh no we do what after we
kill wow we made it who is the worst
jumper that's the question that's a
tough one Griffin how there's only what
took longer that stream I'd be home for
long off and I don't know how that's
possible but they they both work they
both work yeah yeah Craig's getting set
up today was the longest for this piece
of plastic don't do [ __ ] 8,000 up dog
yeah
there's no like YouTube videos on how to
use it or something
trust me I watched everything it didn't
make sense to you it's just glitchy at
least speaking finally [ __ ] ah shoot
[ __ ]
how's about Peaks yeah we can use our
guns final no just wait just wait till
we get to the [ __ ] boss man this is
gonna be [ __ ] awesome
there's no way yeah I know it's just
orc city over here oh oh oh any songs
alright it's a good cartoon I watched
every watched season I think says about
a hop-on well that's that's great well
okay sure yeah that's convenient for you
[Music]
you can join the chat yeah another
healing ripped make read your are not
correct
I'm used to saying Craig I'm used to
blame the Craig for everything but hey
Frank you're an hour and a half late
what's its what's easy to blame I know
I'm just saying in general just
all-around you're just the guy to blame
that's all your general Craig Jack I'm
gonna go blast on these Colossus alright
general what a wild side I'm getting
[ __ ] rocked over there holy mother
bear's one down but they're not doing
anything
down I'm dead
get that revite we need that we don't
know we got it I'm going I'm going on
trying to get too hot I'm trying to get
there's the chest oh oh we get we got
three that's kind of shaver frickin
shader yeah this part [ __ ] is getting
a hat wait where do I go oh you gotta
like it's a partition patient kind of
like I kept having people bouncing my
head it was
go ahead get keys we got a key right oh
no it's this stupid thing I hate this
one we're gonna get in this little area
yeah you got a time I'm not a patient
person go go go number one games were
just fun well you didn't have to learn
shoes you go oh we should do this he's
the first partner to die punch Craig's
ass you're gonna punch me I'm trying to
figure this out all right so for this
for the shoot oh I know that's the whole
point we need to get the rings go now
Griffin no I'm just kidding so what do
you think so far
are you back here do you like Titans
more than warlocks of course he is
horsies I don't know oh [ __ ] I'm sure
what's that yeah we have to fly in space
yeah we first I like this one Griffin
has there ever been a part of a raid
were you bidding complain about it
[Music]
all disgustingly terrible only part of
the raid it's not hard what I just felt
it the Rings get the [ __ ] ring good
center on this middle here we go I got
to I'm gonna get three boys I'm there's
only two left I'm gonna jump I'm gonna
reshoot why it's my are you okay wait
wait wait wait wait I almost got that
one do you jump oh my god you can't you
know just let it slingshot you and then
use your jump in in the air okay I not
is it contains you jump to the net hopes
all right so trying to see how many
there's two left at the bottom were at
the bottom are they left or right
they're left right because I got the
right side one on the left and one on
the right okay I'm right next to Coe
I just want to make it down you know I
mean it's all we need to do now we gotta
hit the rings man we just got make it
down for that second one I see it I'm
like dead on just one right I got
whatever it is I'll just died I got it I
think that's the one I got oh I got this
one
yep that's the one I think I think I got
it to Cheston at the bottom no I don't
see just one right there is there one
right there where I'm shooting right
there I know
thanks for the description what are you
doing that's what I'm so specific no
this thing isn't a life column I had I
can't tell which one we're missing I
know I'm trying to look at the colors
oh [ __ ] what are we missing a small
thing oh my god I just fell to the
bottom and I died does this take you all
the way back up to the top yeah you die
right here yeah yes it does [ __ ] so you
have to say one of your jumps all right
I guess I counter is the best thing for
this right did you get to all right
we're all following each other now this
is crazy
I'm gonna choose doing nonsense
oh I've got this one
I got that Wow there we got it I got it
I think I got at the very end you guys
can die
yeah but if you need your jump for the
other part oh yeah let's go get Pikachu
right now
drop the mic off Pikachu drop to me
[Music]
that was such a burn Craig that was such
a liar you hear all the last you got
going on here I got a couple chuckles oh
good you gave you a pity laugh then not
only do you have me come out to get to
you got me and I forget away tickets to
[ __ ] where two way tickets to ask
[Music]
yeah this is we need to need to know if
okay okay - and to write this thing
shoot [ __ ] I just shoot [ __ ] right so
that's what you're gonna do we're gonna
be runners dressing you're gonna be
you're gonna be so I'll go with Griffin
so Griffin's gonna be paired with me
will be a void so okay which is right
here we're on that yep we're on that
Griffin so you're gonna kill all the ads
you're just gonna do ad and you're gonna
call you're gonna call out so like the
these things I'm shooting at on this big
pyramid thing in the middle they're
gonna have three pistols in there there
they're gonna be no fever I remember
yeah it's like it's gonna yeah it's
gonna say like solar right right so
we're just gonna have three people on
each base and they're gonna call out
what side it starts on and how many of
each we need for the 88 of things and
the runners will just take them to the
corresponding to wherever you guys tell
us we need to go so that's I mean that's
pretty much it and it's gonna go around
okay it's just gonna keep going around
so we just got to make sure we
communicate yeah we got this is your
time there is news this is your time to
review that's not giving me much
comments so okay so you're so Mia we're
gonna need your runners we're gonna need
one more runner here don't say it's
gotta be I've never ran before but I've
I've seen you I know you've never ran
before I don't like to run
her glory the only the only thing I want
Craig's autograph order so I could
[ __ ] wipe my ass what they've ever
done taking a [ __ ] I know that was a
little too far alright so I'm with hype
okay
okay so so high I go ahead and go to a
cranium relic don't play like you're
starting so I could scar is it okay what
am i doing picking mine up
you're just clear nads there Pete you
and letting us know if there's anything
so assuming there's two fire thingy
all right to fire what's the other one
solar yeah there's a soul at t2 solar
and in harken I got one shot alright so
I'm going to solder arrow you can you
pick up another solar I'm gonna go throw
in the the [ __ ] meat charger I'm gonna
call it the meat charger the recharger
II he's charging his meat
that's on our side right that's on our
side
yep yeah an ORAC side yard I got I'm
bringing a solder I'm bringing a solar
over arcs down okay on the void there's
a there's a void and our two voids in
art two boys in there all right all
right that's older sir arrow so whenever
you're ready
what what is it what is it again okay
I'm taking wonder boy to grab this
somebody I'm gonna take this dark we
need another one on boy in the other
window boy yeah actually don't worry
about it Errol I'm mom I got it away
there's another there's another cranium
here so we're I'm gonna bring the ark
over
I got a charge money on what side it's
Boyd side right Oh dance boys I like
that so you get the art we already got
three Boyd it looks like so another and
another
Oh nobody's clearing these ads down are
you talking about i alright so we need
solar there's one there's one they need
one at heart just killed you need one
that all right I'm gonna go rely on
George
wait wait at two people that were down
and nobody revived oh I was going
Griffin just went down I was gone to
robot soccer dick well God don't you
guys start with your nonsense yeah Frank
Frank shows up he's too
he's too [ __ ] Bob Cheers Ringo he
could be Ringo all right so everybody
near their cranes Pikachu can be Linda
McCartney okay where's it is to arc and
to solar on the ark side that's
impossible
I go no it's to arc in one soul yes okay
okay I'm taking one to heart no hectic
there no you know no you said - don't
worry about it yeah piece of [ __ ]
all right I'm gonna put one down
pick up another one
Pikachu if you need help with those ads
let me know okay okay this arcs down
alright there's another r22 Boyden in
art to poison hi I'm wearing the arc
right now okay got it charging all right
I'm gonna take one to voice [ __ ] what's
hitting me do you need me to take oh my
god that wonderboy no no but I will need
arrow I'll need you to come grab a void
come home travel avoid grab now you want
to same time take the arc out yes
sometimes sometimes I done it
right so going off your void on our type
all right airless taking that void over
I'll bring the other one okay there it's
stolen stolen forward an arc already
have one regarding the art alone at the
art charging right now coming over on
some orbs for you Pikachu and over for
that boy okay
all right boy instead like what's that
that's [ __ ] back off if you need to
I'm taking wonderboy yes one of each
it's one of each I know I know I thought
the art coming right now
all right boys turns old for you thank
you right yeah yeah it's on boy it's
good my friend
all right to avoid and then art after
that okay I'm gonna grab my time crane
orbs so to avoid one art yeah so I you
can you can taste it you can take one to
void yep stay the arrow cuz I'm taking
one route right now in there here we
have more time yeah I got one charging
and I got that are charging ring now
homicides orders that want just kill sit
think I'm doing this right I'm going
this solar side of this art right you're
coming to boy they're coming up will
avoid my bed yeah
oh [ __ ] I guess okay there we go
now I'm good boom jerks
I got both boy it was her from before we
need that it we need that art taken out
though I'm coming I'm coming
it needs to be taken out like right now
we got to solder coming to solar and
another art
oh I didn't know we just ran out of
where we were right there
what's up cuz right at the top of kills
huh
advair a fight me to the party on board
no you're not being invited arrow don't
encourage him yeah yeah I don't like
that everybody what to do can we give it
could we give it a second it's Boyd is
the way it's void its - boy - voiceover
oh I'm gonna bring it to ya bring it to
me bring it to me hi yep yep and then we
need us one Solar from you we got the
two void but it's at its that void
nothing on the heart and I won't
okay I'll get and we never heard from
Frank again and that was the last we
heard from Frank I got I got both boy
you just need that Solar I'm looking
hold on
yeah yeah it's it's Boyd Boyd art I'm
taking wonderful day I got one more
another one avoid Boyd Boyd on top one
left and then our tomato bring it here
hi have you got art I got the art okay I
got the news about Darcy oh [ __ ] you
gonna go you're gonna go you got Craig
you got Craig yeah yeah that's gonna be
my revived coconut wait a minute where
is this art on your side
Boyd no no no it's not on Sol thank you
but there's a solar one there too that
nobody called out yeah yeah that one
just came out that would just you know I
have a solar there's all set Boyd nah
bro
that solar was up for a while another I
took it out
I have to get one argh I'm trying to eat
enough
is there another arc there that ya know
ya know the call-out yeah well just
refresh my memory when that when they
come up
you call out cuz I said we had to void
yeah you shoot him but yeah it's gonna
go with it it's gonna go clockwise so
like if it starts on this left corner
avoid it's the next place is gonna be on
you on solar
it'll be your right okay all right
that's what I got and there was I
thought I was I should have called it
out cuz I saw a solar on the corner
there but I thought we had it covered
and I don't think anybody called it out
everything else I called it out of apply
it wrong well I heard to Boyd in a arc I
didn't hear any solar I picked it up all
about going to hand cannon what is it
yeah solar do we do we need another art
we have a solar yeah yep all right I'm
Brandon I'm Brandon art alright
oh my god [ __ ] that up
alright hey kid
[Music]
I'm just making orbs at places [ __ ]
orb dissipations or on one of the Ark's
is up I got it
yeah it's if there's there's our Archon
Archon by soul over here oh no no
there's two arts lives
no it's so it's just the two all right
so there's one arc I see another soul
outside - I got that I got that one art
and I got an art charge all right well
we just need a solar event yeah
then all we need is a solar then yeah
I'm coming yep Greg come over those okay
yeah
do we need an extra charge of any kind I
would wait a little bit because I don't
get unlimited craniums all right there's
one solar two point so I'm gonna take
one avoid okay one solar tee Boyd I'm
gonna take mine Boyd as well yeah
perfect wait so you guys are you guys
covered on Boyd yeah well get a solar
one charge on our monarch side there's
all [ __ ] fell off god dammit sorry
guys okay someone's gonna have to revive
them come up here and pick up a thing
okay when i won i got us cheap i got all
dirty let me down let me deposit yeah I
have it where do I go where do I go I
just got one just got one in you got to
go to art what side of this art you guys
are Kazan left alright I'm coming
mmm-hmm yeah I was charging one that's
where we got [ __ ] up yeah we need that
[ __ ] out where is the solar void side
no it's alright we just know my fault
because I didn't know whether it's a
good place did or not yeah sorry oh
you're good man I didn't know if you had
or not thanks Janko face yeah sorry I
thought you would ask me the place
that's already placed it so when I
grabbed it I grabbed actually I'm
talking arrow I know it's not even for
you're over there and there's one solar
and leaning out of a giant pyramid and
you don't know what we said are we said
art for long no you didn't right the
good thing is we're recording all this
so we get to go back right exactly and
we can always go back here right right
because you're right I'm wrong all the
time when it comes to this game
Jamie pull that [ __ ] kid I know you are
remind us was what are we doing oh yeah
I'm ready I'm ready
all right here picking it up it's solar
side I see one arc one solar two arc one
solar arrow take that to solar I'll go
to heart I'll go to art so arrow you go
solar
yeah I work out
what is so fun I knew you know obviously
I'm leaving Beauty over here
how do your girl yeah that's it all
right
how come my house again it has to come
up over here envoy yet cuz it only
started starts in one spot all right
the arcs one arm challenged I'm bringing
it over yeah that one's hurt alright
hype we have it's gonna be two arc and
one solar again so we need I'm gonna
take one two arc yep you take a solar
and then hike when you're coming back
grab one and bring it so I'll grab one
for our yeah I got you yeah I nice Nami
alright
I need that Oh what happened what
happened oh yeah but we took those out
yes maybe the other ones popped up pipe
you might have hit one of the newer ones
yeah all right communication team
communication you're not saying it's boy
it's boy two aren't one boy I got the
boil up to our convoy I got I'm gonna
start this off right
I've never gotten past this point really
sorry no you might not tonight either
yeah I don't know yeah we're coming
close we I mean we can get past this
yeah the next part hey hey no I'm just I
decided to have faith I'm just telling
you I've never gotten past this part all
right I got the boy
the to our car so uh I mean uh coming
with an article you shoot first light
all right and then the other side of the
solar side we have to art go ahead yeah
to art in one voice so I'm taking
wonderfully I got another arc
the trail your arrow and pick this one
anyway that's on solo right yes oh man
this sucker keeps disappearing annoying
come on I don't even know what we're
calling anymore his shooting stuff you
know I mean I remember come to the far
right and take this far on the other
side [ __ ] like what are they oh yeah
there we go all right I'm gonna take one
the boy home there we go Lex likes down
I'm taking one of those wonderful way it
over take no wonder boy
[Music]
coming it's coming you bringing it
use your supers every time you have I
know I was I was by myself here I was
there you have one job and your job is
to shoot myself because I'm trying to
run this house house house crazy Pikachu
doing but all they need to do with the
[ __ ] crystals not like they have to
line it up bro but I'm telling you
jumping I mean I just made a mistake
that they're gonna die jumping I picked
it up yeah I know what I need to do to
switch in its arc side on art I'm
bringing one as well looking I'm not a
speck okay give me one second give one
second I just try not to die here one of
the cranium okay I'm gone yeah I'm done
I'm done I'm done
I got a cranium going the soul was super
when you get it I don't have it yes I
will I got it yeah but we can kill the
guys I'm playing for the Minotaur that
come when the big Minotaur come that's
funny do you wait it's our side it's our
side yes that's what happened last time
I should have just like shot at these
dumb ones
I know what's next and solar I got it
I just created the [ __ ] oh all right
what do we need because I do we have an
okay to cooking I was - so you're
[ __ ] minotaurs oh I'd be bringing son
of a [ __ ] you need me to bring a soul
yeah I got you hi hi if I got you
it's about to go did anymore I'm here
but I what else do we need don't know
anything
well now Craig what is it it's a holier
than soft wedding I'm bringing a hi-8
one on soul break one
hi Britt avoid if you can't I okay here
I come
okay
so what do you do you bring those things
here and an eight we're gonna have it
another so learn another voice all right
all go alright I'm gonna go grab the
other voice okay all right we need to
put another one with a bubble for me
thank you good oh [ __ ] alright yeah I'm
doing fine it's been great I'm so
remember the ones on the right coming
out I got one that was fun though you
know we almost did better but you don't
time I was close what why that's what I
kept I which I don't understand the
biggest yeah what's the biggest thing is
you just need to stay efficient so like
whatever what it's that and you need to
tell your partners to poke I know
sometimes it'll be you know all three on
one and we don't really have cranium to
spare but I've been having Craig solar
every time and it's really [ __ ] help
me out yeah Pikachu you know how to do
that right I'm not like the cranium yeah
I just pick it up and charge it at the
art yeah should I do where's that it
just lower your person no Arnie would
say three all right easy
I got mine at void right now actually if
it's three void
you guys both shoot one and then with
the half take out the other one I'm
gonna pull in charge in article one I'm
solar for the next one
there's the faster we do it we don't
have to worry about those extra ones
right I'm gonna go what sign is it it's
alright we have three charging right now
right now void no no no but you only
need two for three
yeah
okay all right I'm grabbing all right I
got the bottom one right and then I put
I put damage into the one above it all
right what are they what are the new
ones all right arts down all right
what's the north side we down what's
next
nothing on my side all right it's all I
got
I'm gonna cook one envoy then thank you
like we're doing a cooking show oh yeah
chef boy you know what I do need another
there's no craniums bro there's none
over yeah I know I'll bring another
solar over era
okay so I weakened the bottom one now
there's no craniums work all right I'm
coming with that got one I'm coming with
a solar do we need anything specific
that's not being cooked all right
there's two boys being cooked hold on
yeah there's too many ads there's to
void a to void in an arc I'm balanced
someone needs to revive you I don't know
hollow [ __ ] I got you all right yeah we
got a bro I got the I got the arc charge
okay I don't have I don't see it I got a
cranium you take it we just need that
arc down it's still charging it's coming
up all right we have the - boy - voided
a soul I'm going to solder to solar boy
boy yeah [ __ ] arts thumb and Pikachu
I'm kidding you're doing good you're
doing good piece okay I put one on solar
so do that oh yeah by the time I'll get
over there you can use solar I'm gonna
bring the other boy over right now I get
a run I got this [ __ ] oh my god alright
wait there
alright there's another way I killed it
there we go I got this one boy in one
one art one void one art I'm gonna go
charge the ark I just use my Superette
that shouldn't have hopefully have
enough time we will is there or some
place we will yeah perfect almost
all right you're going under take yours
come on both right solar I got I got a
avoid an article yeah
we're charging all right I just let you
know yeah baby our conductor doing the
job
got it I'm coming
Vegas
got nice got it did we do it
they were do it oh my god did we get it
done yeah yeah okay what are we going
areas justice behind you Griffin oh
let's watch wfe memorable I had a
warlock bond a tech grip was about said
oh I got a [ __ ] masterwork grenade
law I'm alive I got those a 76 is pretty
good though yeah
this bond of this bond is actually
pretty good so we did it yeah I know
what happens next time on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]